So virtual memory management is part of the
kernel of spring, and now we will talk
about how virtual memory management happens in the
spring operating system. There is a per machine virtual
memory manager, and the virtual memory manager is
in charge of managing the linear address space
Of every process. As we know, the linear
address space of a process is what the architecture
gives you, and what the virtual memory manager does
is to break this linear address space into regions. And
you can think of regions as a set of
pages. So you take the linear address space given by
the architecture, that's the process address space Break that
up into regions, but each region is a set of
pages. And each region can be of different sizes.
The second obstraction in the virtual memory management system is
what is called a memory object, and the
idea of breaking up this linear address space into
regions. Is to allow these regions to be mapped
to different memory objects. So, for instance, this region
is mapped to this memory object. This region is
mapped to a portion of this memory object. And
these two regions Different regions of the same address
space are mapped to the same memory object and
this is perfectly fine. So, this is how the
Virtual Memory Manager takes the linear address space and
maps it to these memory objects. And what are
these memory objects? The abstraction of a memory oject
allows a region of virtual memory to be associated
with a backing file. Or it could be the
swap space on the disk, and things like this.
So this memory object is the mechanism by which portions
of the address space can be mapped to
different Entities, which maybe on the dis as
swap space or files in a file system.
All of those are available to the abstraction
of the memory object, so that regions in an address piece can be mapped to the
backing entities. And it is also perfectly possible
that multiple memory objects may map to the same
backing file that is also perfectly possible. so
the way to think about these abstractions is
linear address space broken into regions, regions mapped
to memory objects, and memory object is an abstraction
for Things living on backing store, meaning a
disc. It could be the swap space on
the disc, or it could be specific files
that are being memory mapped in order to access
from a process address space. Those are the
abstractions available in the virtual memory management system,
now we'll see how these memory objects Are
then paged in and brought into the physical memory.